since you guys went at it with the wall
things this is this isn't aluminum I've
been waiting to do this for so long yeah
hit here and then hang on it wow I'm
actually a little impressed you're you
guys want to do an ax throwing contest
remember we just have to suggest the
idea of a plasma grenade more than show
a real live class reneik holy I can
build something that we can just like
save as a preset and just load in every
single comp let's start with just 2d
tracking everything okay look a walk
freaking out dude he's freaking out more
than you are right now yeah she'd really
tone it I'm John I just not freaking out
yeah boom Doh sorry I love particular so
much what I do is I have them start at
like zero percent scale and the longer
that particle exists the bigger it gets
and I also invert that for opacity and
hey Tony you're rollin John here
cranking away on muzzle flashes I just
started going through and dropping in
plasma grenades and stuff we will see
how the next four days ago and it's his
birthday
Oh mrs. Beatty from Y is for my friends
at flight test they sent me a free hat
Niko you get all the flight tests swag
so I legitimately like split my lip last
night when I tried to bite the lens ah
oh wow oh stop it and go to the bathroom
do some work what are you talking about
we'll be here for the next few hours no
cut it and go to the bathroom I don't
want to be waiting on you like me like
that got a girl I don't think John's
coming in today
ya know I think John may be sick
day four of six b45 cousin Eko said we
should get it done in five well I mean
that makes sense just so we can use that
final day for like you know polishing
whatnot I think we're actually on track
to do that
you can put the camera away now please
I'm not tired
right now I left here around 12:30 just
starting to get into a groove Brandon
Alex and Nico come in like we're going
to set the vibe just like well maybe
I'll just play a couple games before we
take a look let's also get the face
actual face thing and give the ugliest
baby you can't make its eyes go outwards
and making them pain the main reason why
effects need to be done today so that I
can move on to other things however we
have time that's the thing I'm not
worried yeah I mean kind of technically
maybe I think we rock spin the
difference
I don't know man I don't know if
everything's gonna be 100% hands off
done by the end of the of the day
somebody
so we did all of that without any eye
protection never do that always wear eye
protection we are idiots you want to be
an intern why now
I really only do VR when I'm [ __ ] up
okay